Hey, so stop me if
you've heard this before.
Don't actually stop the video.
That's just an expression.
But using a trusted
third party like Google
to handle sign-in
for your app can be
a great benefit for everybody.
Your users don't have to come
up with yet another username
and password, and
you as a developer
don't need to hire
a full-time security
team to keep that all safe.
That said, developers
had a few concerns
with Google's original
sign-in library for iOS.
Your users needed
a Google+ account,
which not everybody had.
It was also kind of big.
And if your users didn't have
the Google+ app installed,
it would swap them out to
Safari in order to complete
the sign-in process, which was a
kind of clunky user experience.
This also led to some issues
during the app review process,
which is never a good thing.
But I'm happy to
report that we've
addressed all these concerns
with the new Google Sign-in
library for iOS.
Let's find out more on
this episode of Route 85.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So let's imagine
you've got an app
and you want your
users to sign in, maybe
so they can use their
account on different devices,
maybe so they can access
their data on your server.
You know, there's a number
of different reasons.
And while you could certainly
deal with this yourself
by having your users
create their own usernames
and passwords and storing
them in a database somewhere,
this can be a
hassle, particularly
if you don't have a dedicated
security team working 24/7
to keep that database safe.
Do you?
And no, your cats don't count.
Oh, but that is
good advice, though.
So for many developers,
a better option
is to let a trusted third
party like Google take care
of the sign-in work for you.
Your users can sign into Google
using an account that they
already have, and we give
you some profile information
that you can then
use to identify
that user for your app.
And so that's what
you're looking at here.
I'm clicking the
Sign-in with Google
button so that I can
sign into my account.
I copy and paste my password so
that you people can't see it.
I'm on to you.
I click the Accept button, and
there we go, I'm signed in.
So does this look
somewhat familiar?
I bet you it probably does.
We've had Sign-in available
for many years now as part
of the Google+ library on iOS.
But I'm using the new and
improved Google Sign-in
library, which comes with
a number of improvements
that you may not be aware of.
For starters, I can now sign
in with any Google account,
whether or not I've signed up
for Google+ with that account.
Now, granted if you wanted to
see my Google+ relationship
status, or see who's in my
circles, or what have you,
you could still do that.
You'd add some Google+ scopes
to your sign-in request,
and then I would need
a Google+ account.
But if all you're looking to
do is just sign-in a user so
that you can remember
who they are,
maybe get like their
name and profile
picture, just a plain old Google
account is all I would need.
For another thing, it's
a lot more lightweight.
This new Sign-in
library is about a third
of the size of
the old one, which
means there's less stuff
for users to download,
and, you know, that's
always a good thing.
And finally, the user experience
has been greatly improved.
With the older version
of Sign-in, signing in
involved one of two options.
You could switch over to
the native Google+ app,
or you could switch to Safari.
Now, using the native
Google+ app wasn't so bad.
In fact, it was pretty slick.
It was nice.
But not everybody
had that installed,
which meant that they were stuck
with swapping out to Safari,
and this tended to be a less
slick experience and one
that sometimes lead to
rejections during the app
approval process.
And that didn't
just make users sad,
it made developers sad, too.
So with the new version
of Google Sign-in,
we'll first try and switch you
over to any native Google app
you might be signed
in to, whether that's
Google Search, or YouTube,
Maps, or what have you.
But if your user doesn't
have any of those installed,
well, that's not a problem.
We now slide up the
sign-in page in a UIWebView
right within the application.
There's no more
switching out to Safari.
Hurray!
Oh, and both these experiences
get a whole lot better
in iOS 9.
For starters, we're able to
use a Safari view controller
for the embedded WebView,
which is not only
more secure than
using the old WebView,
but it also means that
if your user has already
logged into Google
in Safari, they
don't need to do it again
when they sign in to your app.
So that whole enter your
username and password thing
you saw earlier, we
get to skip that.
And switching to a native app
is now super, super slick.
Since iOS 9 is in beta,
according to Apple's NDA,
I'm technically not
allowed to show you
what it looks like, so this
picture of a unicorn barfing
a rainbow will have to give
you a general idea of how great
it is.
But seriously, the
whole experience,
it looks really nice in iOS 9.
The team did a really good job.
I think you're going
to be happy here.
So to get started
using Google Sign-in,
you can check out our
documentation here.
Please note that the old Sign-in
experience is still available
as part of the Google+ library
and still sometimes shows up
in search results.
So you want to make
sure you're looking
at the documentation
with the green header
here, not this documentation
with the red one.
But hey, you've made it
to the end of this video,
so you must like videos,
or maybe you just like me.
How you doing?
Either way, how
about I treat you
to a little video of my walking
through the process of adding
Google Sign-in to an app.
Com on, follow along.
It'll be fun.
As for the rest of you, if
you don't like screencast,
that's OK.
I'll still see you
soon on Route 85.
[MUSIC PLAYING]